on March 31st I sent out a tweet saying
I no longer hear any experts claiming
cash is trash anymore
what happened question mark that tweet
goes out right after three point two
eight million people apply for
unemployment and right after six point
six five million people apply for
unemployment ten million people in the
month of March we're at 16 million
people in 21 days nowadays markets
tanked everybody wishes that a little
bit more cash and when I send that tweet
out people started coming back same path
are you talking about this person I
think he's talking about this person
I think he's time on Ray Dalio and in a
week after that Ray Dalio is asked do
you believe cash is still trash and he
says I believe cash is still trash today
I am responding to the concept of is
cash still trash according to Ray Dalio
[Music]
this whole concept of cash is still
trash is another example of people not
asking the right question because the
question they're asking maybe doesn't
apply to the face of their life there
currently I let me explain to what I
mean by this you know how people ask a
billionaire and they say so what's your
current schedule looks like and he says
I wake up at 7:30 and I go do this oh my
gosh I thought you had to sleep for five
six hours you're asking him while he's a
billionaire why don't you ask him while
he was starting up his company trying to
make the whole company work out what was
your schedule then that's the right
question so let me explain to what I
mean by this in America when it comes
down to networks wealth there's
different brackets you following I want
to talk about some of the ones here one
of them is affluent in America if you
have a hundred thousand dollars two
million dollars of liquid network you
are considered part of the affluent
class if you have a million dollars to
five million dollars of liquid network
you're part of the high network class if
you have five million to 30 million
you're part of a very high net worth
which by the way there's four point
seven nine five million of those in
America of which three hundred
ninety-three thousand five hundred of
those are specifically just from New
York City and then you have the ultra
high-net-worth which is somebody that
has 30 million to 999 million dollars of
liquid net worth there was only seventy
three thousand one hundred ten of those
88 sixty five in New York City
that puts in a point zero zero three
percent of America let me say it again
not in the one percent not in the ten
percent not at the point one percent
during the point zero zero three percent
of America then comes the billionaire
class which you gotta have a billion
dollars or more to be part of that
category so now when I'm explaining this
to you you may be looking at me saying
Pat I don't know where you're going with
this what percentage of the clientele
that Ray Dalio deals with do you think
are just affluent you think he's dealing
with people that don't have $100,000 or
you think Ray Dalio is dealing with
ultra high net worth or you think he's
dealing with institutional money running
a hedge fund or you think he's dealing
with billionaires you think he's sitting
down with middle America and family
saying cash is trash let me continue
here so you get the idea where I'm going
by the way some fun facts about all
trying Network folks sixty-five percent
of them are self-made on how they make
their money out of these ultra
high-net-worth they average a total of
eight cars they own that's a study done
by rolls-royce three out of the four
ultra high-net-worth owner jet and
twenty two percent of them made their
money in the follow-on industries
finance insurance banking and
investments so now we kind of have an
idea by these different level classes
but where are we going with this this is
one class now let's talk about the other
class the other class is household
income range where am I going with this
here's what I'm going with this less
than twenty thousand dollars in America
income less than twenty thousand dollars
of income per year there's a nineteen
point seven million of those that's
considered below or near poverty level
that's nearly twenty million Americans
that make less than twenty thousand out
of your income then you have twenty to
forty four thousand 999 that's twenty
eight point seven million of them that's
considered low income if you're making
between forty five to one thirty nine
that's fifty seven million of them
that's considered middle class your
middle class if you're making 139 per
year 140 to 149 there's 2.6 million
that's part of the upper middle class
150 to 199 is high income and last but
not least those of you that make two
hundred plus thousand dollars per year
which there's nine point nine million of
you you're officially in the highest tax
bracket so remember so far we've looked
at two different things
you've got wealth liquid net worth and
then you have income go from below
poverty level to do
that are at the highest tax bracket so
where am I going with this cash is trash
you think cash is trash to this
community maybe yes
community maybe you know cash is king
here maybe cash is trash when you're an
ultra light ultra high-net-worth and
that's probably the people that rate
value speaking to the most does that
apply to majority of America probably
not maybe to the point zero zero three
percent of America so some of you guys
are watching say oh my gosh I have cash
I should get rid of it because such and
such persons that cash is now get let me
go a little bit deeper to validate my
argument for you you ready for this they
did a study to see different levels of
assets that people have from $10,000 all
the way down to billion dollars what
percentage goes into which asset let me
go a little deeper it's people that have
$10,000 people that have $100,000 a
million dollars ten million dollars 100
million dollars and a billion dollars
then the assets they looked at were the
following liquid primary residence
vehicles retirement or an IRA life
insurance mutual funds stocks fixed
income managed assets maybe in a trust
real estate and business interest when
they looked at these different
categories here's a conclusion that came
up with if you look at the screen you
will get an idea based on the color
differences of where that money is going
to at the lowest level where people that
only have $10,000 notice how the biggest
percentage of their assets are in liquid
cash do you notice that and notice how
the second level of $100,000 the biggest
percentage becomes their primary
residence
and then it gets lower because most
people with $10,000 they typically
cannot afford to buy a house and those
with $100,000 typically owned a
residence and then when you go to a
million dollars
most people's net worth is not tied to
their residence and then all the way
down to a billion dollars if you look at
it closely you will notice the wealthier
have the biggest chunk of their wealth
high to business interest let me say
this again the wealthier the biggest
chunk of their assets is tied to
business interest me relation to study
with 800 ultra high-net-worth
individuals to see how they invested
money and where their assets was 55% was
in stocks 21% bonds 15% cash once again
15% cash 6% alternative investments and
3% as other so when you look at this
data you see this here
from where their assets are you see this
here where their assets are now you see
why Ray Dalio is absolutely right
depending on which community is speaking
to and radios advice doesn't apply to
you if you're in a complete different
situation I've never met a venture
capitalist or somebody who started a
company that's sold it for billion
dollars or 100 million dollars or even
50 million dollars I have never met
somebody who didn't say the value of
cash to have when the tough times come
that cash allows you to survive
challenging times how many startups the
the cemetery of startups with great
ideas great companies great teams great
founders great systems everything was
great they ran out of cash how many how
many companies are buried at the
cemetery of startups I lack cash many of
them many of them you'll never hear
about because they ran out of cash so
the concept of cash has to do with what
phase of your life you're in when
somebody says well I think Pat is trying
to debate Ray Dalio here's a man worth
19 billion dollars writes a book that
sells nearly 4 million copies with Simon
& Schuster I had every single one of my
executives read his book I had every
single one of my sales associates read
his book over 14,000 agents I had people
write a paper on it because of the way
he mused it's a 600 page book his
philosophies work he and I sat down
together and had an incredible
conversation I don't know how many views
the video has I would say shy of a
million views because it's in depth this
is a man that knows economy and finances
and he has strong opinions about it but
never forget who's his community the
community may not be you you may be
working on getting to a certain level to
be an ultra high-net-worth where yes
cash is more trash the wealthier you get
than when you're coming up so don't take
advice from people based on a face you
are not at yet take the advice from the
person saying hey
mr. Dahle Oh if I'm at this level how
much cash do you think I need if I'm
starting the company and I don't have a
lot of money
do you think I should dispose you know
get rid of all my cash and buy
technology or do you think I should stay
liquid I'm gonna he's gonna give you
advice to say you got to hang on to your
cash because this is a different story
one blanket statement doesn't apply to
everybody it only applies to a community
so you need another layer and another
layer and another layer of question to
be asked to get to what the real valid
advice or counsel is to you in your face
of your life so having said that I got a
couple of things I want you to do if
you've not watched my interview with
Radar you'll click on a link over here
to watch that it's a very very different
kind of an interview because we talked
about China Great Depression economy
philosophy his investment philosophy
click on it again if you've not watched
it to go through it and if you want
today's content that we covered in an
infographic maybe you want to look at
and say listen I want to become ultra
high net porn you want to put this right
next to your computer on your screen or
on your phone or print it out and share
with the people that you work with sales
guys wherever it is if you can text the
word wealth to three one zero three four
zero one one thirty two again wealth
text it to three one zero three four
zero one one three two will text you
back the infographic and if you're not
in the States if you go into the
description click to subscribe to our
newsletter we'll send you it in for
graphic as well and if you haven't
subscribed to the channel click over
here to subscribe thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye
you
[Music]